like Latin media and radio wasn't
talking too much about Bernie Sanders
and what he stands for so that's why I
decided to write a Corey though about
everything he's he wants to do for us
billions of humans you're watching the
news and and you have Hillary and Trump
Hillary and Trump a lot of Latinos think
those are our only options but there's
not there's a lot more options Bernie
Sanders is another option I'm sorry if
you're watching this thank you if we
were to write a song about Donald Trump
honestly I
we wouldn't write a song you know
talking bad about him or bashing I think
we would write a song to try to change
his views on a lot of things
he call the palace see me this alley